welcome to Hannity as we now kickoff
what will be an exciting a busy news
week and probably a week of a boomerang
we start though tonight with a Fox News
Alert because at this hour the hostile
Iranian regime is on a mission to
destabilize the free world today the
rogue state claimed they had discovered
a secret CIA spy ring the President and
Secretary of State Pompeo they're
calling the latest allegation lies
propaganda we will have a full report
throughout the evening tonight but first
liars conspiracy theorists and con
artists in the Democratic Party in the
media they are breathlessly hysterically
anxiously awaiting Robert Muller's
public testimony this Wednesday starting
at 8:30 a.m. it'll be right here on the
Fox News Channel Muller will appear
before two House committees led by two
of the biggest political hacks two of
the biggest liars in the United States
Congress of course the one the Cowardly
Adam Schiff of course the one we have on
tape actually conspiring and trying to
get information from the Russians and
Jerry Nadler now as you know chef and
Nadler a two hyper-partisan conspiracy
theorists they only pander to the
lunatic wind of the the wing of the
Democratic Party which now appears to be
the whole party and they are the biggest
spokespeople in the media mob and their
friends go to bat for them every day now
nearly two plus years no evidence
they've been telling people again and
again and again you we the American
people that our duly elected president
was a Russian op spreading a lies a hoax
conspiring with Russia pushing one
conspiracy theory one hoax right after
another one lie after another promising
one smoking gun after another we now
have four separate investigations all of
them including the molar report have
determined that Trump Russia collusion
it never happened let's go to the Muller
report itself it concluded quote the
investigation did not establish that
members of the Trump campaign conspired
or coordinated with the Russian
government in its election interference
activities they did not conspire that's
the fourth set
for an investigation now they want an
investigation number five six seven
eight nine and ten no collusion no
conspiracy no obstruction no underlying
crime and this president and his entire
administration everybody that was asked
cooperated that's right the president
gave answers everybody in the White
House appearing before one congressional
committee after another going to the
special council one after another all
encouraged by the way all campaign all
White House staff to testify and they
all did not a single instance of
executive privilege was ever applied
during the special counsel probe Oh
how's that obstructionist even the White
House Counsel Dom McGann this to me is
insane
even he was allowed to testify for over
30 hours and independent counsel former
independent counsel Ken Starr called
this administration's cooperation
unprecedented and it was
did the president express frustration
about the ongoing witch-hunt that he was
found innocent up for a fourth time yes
he did I don't blame him did he complain
about the time that his administration
was forced now to dedicate to an
absolute conspiracy theory of hopes and
lies yeah I think any normal person
would feel that way but he never fired
Robert Muller II didn't fire acting AG
rod Rosenstein he didn't impede the
investigation he assisted and asked
those around them to assist in the
investigation any way that they can and
then when the Attorney General bar the
Deputy Attorney General Rod Rosenstein
the nonpartisan Office of Legal Counsel
yeah they looked at it there was they
decided pretty much in minutes no
obstruction of justice either Robert
Muller himself admitted no obstruction
charges were recommended by his Office
of Special Counsel because there was not
sufficient evidence of obstruction just
because you can't exonerate doesn't mean
there's evidence of obstruction and that
determination he pointed out was made
without any consideration as it regards
the legal precedent DOJ policy has to or
constitutional issues regarding whether
whether or not a sitting president can
be charged with a crime over the weekend
the cowardly liar shift Nadler well they
were living in an alternative you
verse alternate-reality or once again
lying for political gain and once again
generating false hope expectations that
Donald Trump will be taken out of the
White House and handcuffs or impeached
or worse
take a look I mean it's been clear you
know from Bob Muller that he felt and
the Justice Department feels bound by
this Office of Legal Counsel opinion
that you can't indict a sitting
president but he is a essentially
unindicted co-conspirator he's been
identified as an individual one well the
report presents very substantial
evidence that the president is guilty of
high crimes and misdemeanors and we have
to present that or that malla present
those facts to the American people and
then see where we go from there because
the administration must be held
accountable and no president can be can
be above the law no he is not an
unindicted co-conspirator and no if
you'd read the Constitution noting that
you're talking about represents high
crimes or misdemeanors none of it and
for Democrats mulish testimony
it's not about seeking the truth they
don't want justice they want another
bite at the Apple the first four times
have failed they want to write that
maybe they believe their own lies at
this point instead as the LA Times
pointed out this last-ditch smear effort
against Donald Trump is politically
motivated and it is after all the
special counsels report has been out
there for months Muller said that his
writing will speak for itself that will
be by the way his introduction is
opening comments on Wednesday and he
said that any testimony would merely
echo what's in the report in other words
we'll learn nothing and two short days
we'll know if Robert Muller is a man of
his word or if he's going to flip-flop
and flail and maybe have the Attorney
General bar bail him out yet again
because the nine and a half minute press
conference was a disaster for him either
way Republicans though well they have an
amazing opportunity to seek answers on
some very important issues and questions
now tomorrow night on this program I am
going to give a tutorial to those in
Congress on the Republican side that
will have an opportunity to question mr.
Muller and I'm gonna give you my
questions and also the way I would ask
them and the follow-ups that should be
immediate
you only have five minutes you got to
make it count and I'll explain how I
would do it if you're interested when we
come back also tonight later in the
program Sarah Carter Greg chair are they
going to break down every question that
robert muller must be asked by the
republicans at the hearing and by the
way they won't appear in the Muller
report so he can't say oh it's Paige
whatever now it's right in there because
he didn't answer those questions